so you notice with this course video at
least at the beginning I'm in my home
office and I'm using my chalkboard and
you know where is the Mayoress classroom
the Marist rock board you might be
wondering that well you know there's
there's a long story about that but I'm
going to tell you the short story which
is simply that like a dummy I set up the
camera I got to talking with my students
and actually walked up looked at the
camera and forgot to hit record and
fortunately one of the students in my
class pointed out to me as I was about
15 minutes into the class session after
he had some excellent conversations
between between myself and some of my my
really bright students I've got a really
great crop of intro students this
semester at Marist College she pointed
out to me that the camera was not on so
then we turned it on and you'll see the
footage of that you know fairly shortly
but I actually we had such a great
discussion before I found out that the
camera wasn't on I wanted to try to
replicate as much of it as I couldn't
obviously I can't do that with student
input which which is kind of a shame
because like I said you know I've got
some really smart students asking some
great questions in my class this
semester in intro and I wish that you
know we could we could actually hear
them doing that but this is you know as
best as we can for for a substitute and
you know I use these videos to try to
provide a resource for my students who
maybe can't make it to class that
particular day and it's also for for the
viewers we are discussing augustine's on
free choice to the will book to this
time and the first thing that I wanted
to say is this particular book is
ranging over a lot of material and it's
starting out with this question you know
why did God give us free will book one
asked is God responsible for evil and we
saw that Waga Steen's way of dealing
with that is
to say no God gave us the capacity to
choose freely which way we're going to
go if we choose rightly we end up
producing good and we become good if we
go the wrong way we end up producing
evil and we in fact become evil and
incur certain penalties as a result and
what this came down to was the human
will which way is the human will
oriented is oriented towards higher
things
towards eternal things towards goods
which are not able to be taken away from
us without us you know without
transgressing our will which includes by
the way having a good will or do we
orient ourselves primarily towards
towards lower things towards our own
passions and desires towards the things
that that call to them and evoke them
because we have to we have to make a
balance we have to make a trade-off and
you can't have both of them Augustine
would say most of the time if you're
really really lucky you you get to but
most people aren't in that situation so
sooner or later you're gonna make
important choices about how you order
goods right so you order goods wrongly
that's bad order Goods rightly that's
good and the goodness is in our will so
that gets got off the hook God created
the world God created human beings God
created all of our capacities God
created the various goods which we can
rightly use or wrongly use that seems to
get got off the hook because you can say
well human beings are responsible for
for the evil which they they cause human
beings are the ones who choose wrongly
and it's not God's fault that that
happened but you know Avvo Deus points
out and you know students could point
this out as well and we saw this also in
in cicero's on the nature of the gods
not so much in terms of will but in
terms of reason you can still ask this
question look god why did you give us
freewill
if you knew that we could misuse it so
that's what this dialogue
in this book is actually about in this
this portion of the dialogue but you'll
notice when you when you read through
this it takes an awful lot of what looks
like at first meandering and digressions
and and getting off track into all sorts
of other interesting topics before you
come back to it at the very end now
there's a reason for that
Augustine is actually leading us through
a lot of important topics along the way
that we we have to develop a good
understanding of in order to understand
his his response to this this question
now I'm gonna come back to this in a
moment I want to talk about a few other
things that my students brought up so
one thing that the students were curious
about is Augustine talks a lot about
punishment and reward and so why is that
you know what's going on there a lot of
people tend to think of religion and
religious doctrines and religious people
as if they're all about the the
afterlife and just be a nice person
because then God's gonna reward you be a
bad person God will get you right and I
think there are a lot of people that who
see things this way
Augustine is is not really one of them
and no Christian philosopher who is both
Christian and a philosopher and this
would go for the other monotheistic
religions as well Judaism Islam no
person who's really a philosopher and
any any real sense would say that it's
all just about reward and Punishment at
the end you know after this life there
is some respect in which the choices
that we're making in this present life
have to do with the kind of people that
we are they're not just reflective of
that they make us into the kind of
people we are and if we make the right
choices we're opening ourselves up for
the possibility of genuine happiness not
only in the afterlife but also including
in in this life for enjoying the the
highest goods and if we make the wrong
choices
for relatively we are in effect maybe
not you know with the the first wrong
choice but but over over time cutting
ourselves off from the possibility of
enjoying the higher goods or perhaps
even recognizing them as higher Goods
and so we're gonna we're gonna be stuck
with the lower goods which are goods but
they're not truly satisfying and we're
gonna get all mixed up and and
disordered and we're probably not even
gonna enjoy these goods that much so I
brought up somebody else who were gonna
study in the course of the semester
state Ansel since mom said something
really interesting about punishment
report and this really through a lot of
people and I brought this up to my class
he said at one point and I'm just sort
of paraphrasing here I would be fine
with going to hell if I were to go down
to hell by some sort of mistake and I
didn't actually deserve to be there and
correspondingly going to heaven if I
wasn't actually deserving of going to
heaven really wouldn't be that good and
people are like what is this what is he
talking about you know having to tell
good place bad place well you know again
the Anselm is a fairly typical Christian
philosopher in this respect he thinks
about it this way
if you were to go down to hell through
some sort of cosmic bureaucratic mistake
right you wouldn't really suffer the way
that people in Hell do because people in
Hell are suffering precisely because of
who they are the condition that they're
in it's not just about flames or you
know doubles poking you or you know
Dante's descriptions or stuff like that
the worst part of Hell and this comes
very clearly across in Dante and other
things is the despair the fact that
you're stuck with yourself
and you can't change and you get to
actually know yourself to some extent in
a way that perhaps was cut off from you
in this life and you don't like it and
to go to heaven if you were to like make
it into heaven well like in Grimm's
fairy tales you know those little tailor
sneaks into heaven right because it
talks of Saint Peter you know those
sorts of things wouldn't really fly
because the people who enjoy heaven are
the ones who actually have souls that
are pure and a soul that's pure doesn't
mean you know like you never did
anything wrong or anything like that or
God forgave you it means that you've
developed virtue and you develop wisdom
that's really essential for Augustine
that's really central for for all these
other people that we're talking about as
well so you know in a sense reward and
Punishment come from what you do and God
just kind of recognizes and ratifies it
and and makes things work out the way
they do but if you pick the wrong course
of life you're screwing up your soul
according to somebody like Augustine and
sure in his providential order God might
you know arrange things so bad things
happen to you as a result but bad things
are gonna happen to you by your own
doing as a result you're not gonna be
happy so that helped my students they
said yeah okay that makes some sense
then we started talking about this
question again why did God give us
freewill and my students several them
immediately pointed out where Augustine
is actually going to be going and I'm
not sure if they actually have read book
three yet but he's gonna talk about this
a lot in book 3 why did God give us free
will because free will is a is a a good
really high good in the order of things
it makes it possible for us to
participate in creation in reality in a
way that transcends so many other things
it raises us to a higher degree
even if we screw it up even if we misuse
it
it raises us to a higher state and some
of my students frame this in terms of
meaning if you didn't have free will if
your decisions we're just sort of
automatically or mechanistically made
for you by by factors over which you
have no control then your actions really
wouldn't have significance or meaning
and they weren't thinking so much in
terms of like moral meaning but we ended
up steering ourselves towards that we
are moral beings that's part of what it
is to be a human being we recognize
moral values and dis values and that's
part of what makes life so interesting
that's part of what makes some things
boring when when that that dimension is
is lacking so my students were really on
the right track in 20min up I had
another student who also pointed out
well you know if God doesn't give you
free will then God really can't do much
of anything with you Kenny he just sort
of sets you up and you go on your own
way like an automaton and that's it
instead God kind of tests us by giving
us freewill and seeing what we're gonna
do with it
and yes it's an open question whether
God can even you know predict in some
sense why I've seen thinks they can but
we'll talk about that later okay predict
what we're gonna do with it so that's an
interesting issue and now we come to a
vote hisses question so Augustine says
look God gave you free will and you know
you can figure out why he gave it to you
uh he gave it to you so you can do the
right thing so you can participate in
this this dimension of moral goodness
that otherwise you couldn't I mean you
could do good things like take care of
people but if it was only because you
were determined to act
way we'd say yeah there's something
missing there there's something lacking
that person is not freely choosing to do
that so Augustine says man is something
good and cannot do right except when he
so wishes she ought to have free will he
want to have free will he needs to have
free will without which he could not do
right and then you know he says now I
understand some people say we can send
we can do wrong we can screw up through
free will so he says because this occurs
for your free will
we must not suppose a God gave man free
will for the purpose of sinning for the
purpose of doing the wrong things and we
talked a little bit in that class too
about what what Augustine means by sin
it's not so much offense against God
it's doing the wrong thing he says it's
a sufficient reason why it ought to be
given that man cannot live rightly
without it so without being given free
will which has a purpose which is to do
the right thing you'd be missing out on
this and he says you know God tells you
this by when he punishes he says God
says to that person why did you not use
your free will for the purpose for which
I gave it to you that is to do right why
did you screw up why'd you use it for
all sorts of other crazy stuff well you
know that I didn't I didn't say go do
that you know if you think about some of
the biblical stories you know God could
you could imagine God talking with Cain
and you can say well look you shouldn't
be giving me free will if you didn't
want me to kill my brother cuz you know
you could have seen that one coming you
know and and God would say something
like you think that's why I gave it to
you it's sort of like you know being
given a computer and no you know you
could use your computer to create
viruses that destroy other people's
computers and you know actually there
are some people who give computers to
other people for that reason you know in
cyber warfare and stuff like that but
let's just let's just go with you know
the normal thing if I give you the
computer so you can actually get your
homework done where you can surf the web
and do shopping well if you use it for
some other bad purpose and I've given it
to you I can say hey
I didn't want you to do that that that
wasn't what I intended you you to do it
I said well you know you knew I could do
that yeah but I actually thought you'd
have enough on the ball not to do that
so if odious actually raises a good
question he says wait a second we're
talking about God here right we're not
just talking about some some guy who has
a computer and gives it to his kid and
the kid does the wrong thing with that
we're talking about God God is
transcendent God is all-knowing
all-powerful couldn't he figure out
ahead of time that this would be this
would be a bad idea
couldn't he you know think ahead he says
I agree that God gave it meaning free
will but I ask you do you not think that
if it was given for the purpose of good
conduct it ought to have been possible
it ought not to have been possible to
misuse it for sin it's not possible to
misuse justice itself which is virtue
which is given demand that he may live
rightly so maybe you know the will
should be like that maybe God should
give us free wills but they're not
they're not completely free or they're
they're oriented in certain ways where
they're not gonna actually go wrong or
maybe you know there should be like a
free will shop so if your free will gets
screwed up you get a free pass to go in
there and they fix it for you with a
little bit of tinkering and you come out
and now you get a free will that
actually is going to do the right thing
well it can't work like that I used
another example - I used my iPhone which
I don't I don't have in front of me
right now and I said you know think
about it this way a voting this is
saying something along the lines of you
get an iPhone and now you could use it
for all sorts of bad things like say
cyberbullying it was a big topic these
days right and nobody should be
cyberbullying and you can use your
iPhone for that as a matter of fact it
might be more useful because you can be
like johnny-on-the-spot with you can
take you know video of somebody in
to YouTube or you can get on Facebook
and say nasty things about people or
Twitter or whatever you like you know
send emails to people do all do all
sorts of things along those lines right
it's more convenient than carrying
around a laptop or maybe even an iPad or
or any other kind of tablet so imagine
that your parent gives you an iPhone and
says I don't want you to use this for
any bad purposes I want you to use this
for all sorts of good purposes now you
go and use it for cyberbullying and your
parents says well I didn't mean for you
to do that that was the wrong thing as a
matter of fact I told you not to do that
and then you say to your parent yeah but
if you didn't want me to do it you
should have like you know disabled some
some functionality perhaps so maybe your
parent could put a governor and as soon
as like certain words start popping up
you know like things you would say to
cyberbully somebody and yeah almost
anything account of cyberbullying these
days right we use the tournament's also
loosely so maybe any sort of mean
language you know a little pop up thing
comes up and says are you sure you want
to say that and then if you push yes
then it says no I'm not gonna let you do
that that would be sort of like what of
odious is talking about why didn't God
give us a kind of internal governor or
something that would keep us from
misusing free will and I brought up and
I asked my students how many of you have
encountered content filters when you're
trying to do research we talked about
you know some of the things that were
filtered and in their their high schools
you know like some of them can't even
see YouTube in high school or access
most of the net and if you type in any
sort of word like sex or something like
that usually all sorts of filters kick
in right now if you're researching cars
that might not be a big deal let's say
that you're actually researching the
history of sexuality now you you go to
type stuff in and it just says no I
can't go to that
I can't go to that so I can't go to that
site can't go to that site you're really
restricted in what you're able to do
aren't you you're not able to make the
progress that you would like to be able
to make it cuts you off from a lot of
stuff and I actually brought up an
example from my own my own time back
when I was a graduate student so this is
a long time ago
I had a friend who worked in a computer
lab at SIU where I was going to grad
school and every single day they didn't
have content filters right
every single day he would have to go
through the entire lab and like get rid
of all the pornography that people were
looking at sometimes just walking away
with porn still on the screen and then
sometimes like hiding in folders and
things like that and you would think wow
that that really takes some guts to let
you know be sitting there with some
other people next to you'd be looking at
porn people will do that people will
misuse the resources that you give them
to do all sorts of crazy things now
you've got a trade-off if you're willing
to restrict things and you can cut out
the you know people surfing the net for
porn while they're supposed to be doing
something productive with the computer
which the college is providing to them
but now they can't do a lot of other
things now they can't actually research
some important topics now think about
this in terms of the will if you had a
will that had kind of like content
filters on it you know alarm bells go
off when you start thinking about doing
something naughty well you'd be
restricted you wouldn't really have free
will that would you and there would be a
certain dimension to this that would be
lacking this is where Augustine is going
to go towards the end and and will will
pick up on that
so I've summarized as best as I could
the kind of
stations that we had and now you'll see
the rest of the class all right so yeah
did that actually be based off of our
like the perception of comparison like
how our mind works if you only knew good
you would have no concept of that and
you could not really understand good
yeah I mean there is something to that
an Augustine is receptive to that to
that idea ideally I mean if you actually
were in such a case that he never
screwed up ever imagined Adam and Eve
would never like eaten the Apple or
quince or whatever it was nobody
actually knows what was and the story
and I said serpent forget you know we
recognize you as being a bad influence
they would have enjoyed you know
eternity forever is it better that they
underwent some some damage on going more
on seeing the consequences of their
actions
maybe I think about it some of the
consequences the reactions one kid
killing another kid that's that's pretty
bad
there is a some there is a seduction
that because of the badness that we we
see goodness takes on a greater meaning
or relief or intensity or something like
that just when you're hungry you know
there is there is something like that
but good still has a fundamental
ontological we would say priority over
evil meaning that good of its own nature
is prior to evil it's not as if you know
good only by it not being able being not
evil good is first and then evil is a
lack or privation of corruption or
something like that
at least obviously so we'll come to that
in a moment
so let's let's go on we talked about
about why God might give us fruit but
we'll come back to that in the very end
since you know I messed up at the camera
let's talk about next the degrees of
being then we saw this idea before with
cicero of the Stoics and you know others
like plants and the animals and human
beings and then fully rational beings
why obviously was doing something kind
of similar to that he says if you exist
of course you exist right if there's any
you answering because then you must
exist so one of the degrees of being is
existence what we might call bare
existence and some actually calls this
naked existence new to Vanessa and all
it is then is to exist most stones
stones exist where this
piece of piece of chalk right here it
has no consciousness it has certain
properties right we know through through
what through experience and also through
science but that's it this is never
going to be anything more than that a
piece of chalk or some lines on the
floor
what's higher than that what's more
organized than that what he has greater
ontological depth and density we would
say if we want to speak in metaphysical
terms living then think about what a
living being has to do this can't do
anything only somebody moving in
somebody changing it makes it any other
than anything other than it is I mean
it's it's atoms can react to the very
honest but that's purely mechanistic
processes this is never going to worry
about you know whether it's to be larger
it doesn't care whether it gets bigger
or smaller whether I drop it or break it
there's nothing to that living things
now are very different they eat they
grow they seek they desire they many of
them sense don't they
this is a very this is a huge shift from
one level of being to the next then
there's another major almost like
quantum leap and you put this in terms
of understanding plants don't understand
any of that actually from his from
Harding's perspective animals don't even
understand anything either they they
sense things but they don't know that
they sense things you see the difference
between them if I have to be right now
what are you seeing you can give me sort
of a report right some guy
red tie and black and there's a black or
basket what your hear my voice using air
conditioner or heat or whatever it is
travel over no ways if I ask you
something like are you sure you're
hearing that that pumps like doesn't the
animals don't do that the animals don't
say how are my senses to see to me we
make movies about this we write entire
books about we have a radically
different level of being than the
animals do so he says there are these
three existence life understanding a
stone exists and animal lives I don't
think a stone lizard an animal
understands but it's quite certain that
a person who understands also exists in
live so if you have this level you have
both of these two if you have this Level
II of this one but if you're down at
this level you don't even have any
problems so we're doing other things fit
in here the honesty now is looking at
these different levels of being where
the things fit in with our faculties how
do we know this how do we how do we
experience those how did you get
yourself here to the classroom today
yeah through like making decisions and
being aware what's going on yeah how are
you aware of what's going on yeah so
living things yeah
senses and we usually think of it as
five senses that's kind of arbitrary
because you know touch really covers a
huge amount
you know pressure is different than the
heat cold different than wrongness so I
miss let's say there's this five senses
right is that's the traditional way of
looking at the five senses actually
don't tell you that much by themselves
they tell you a lot about what it is
that they're focused on so you know for
instance you're hearing me right now I'm
talking to you you're hearing certain
sound waves that are impacting under
yours the scientific explanation we can
do is sort of you know phenomenological
experiential thing you hear a person
talking that's just as good of a
description as talking about sound waves
how do you actually perceive that the as
a person talking how do you make sense
out of that that's what leads to what
Augustine calls the inner sense the five
senses give you certain information the
inner sense at least at the level of the
animal is what you use to make to
actually grasp and the object is an
object rather than is just a bunch of
you know colors there think about when
you look at a video screen all you're
actually seeing is what pixels and what
are pixels you have little tiny colored
dots and is it your eye that's actually
putting those together into an image
that you recognize as what
let's say you're shopping on ebay you
know you see something that you like
that object that you you want to have is
it your eye that's doing all that work
no it's something else
that's compiling all this information
and putting it together you know yeah
actually you know the human eye in
itself face tougher the chemistry and of
mind everything you see is actually
upside down but yeah yeah coming to a
lens yeah there's like a whole optics
thing going on there's all sorts of ways
the information can get screwed up you
know interesting now the inner sense is
actually what compiles all these things
and puts them together and the inner
sense is also concerned with telling us
so you are watching the TV and now you
can't actually smell the food on the TV
yeah maybe we'll have smell-o-vision
someday like a Futurama
right now in camp so now you're you're
hungry yeah a pizza commercial comes up
and you see a pizza and now you know to
know by the way a lot of the food that
you see in those commercials isn't
actually real food it's like the
replicas because the real food doesn't
look as appetizing
under the camera as these wax and
plastic replicas other people make so
also for stock photography they do this
tell them you're looking at that what
sense is involved there at most - right
site and maybe hearing because here the
pizza sizzles and it takes about the
oven
yeah it makes you it makes your desired
pizza it doesn't it's a voting something
here your your memory is involved but
also it's inner sense and it says man
I'd like to have a pizza right about now
I like pizza I think it tasted Pete's I
like the smell of pizza you're not
actually smelling it but your mind is
putting it together in that in that way
we experience these kind of things all
the time
now that is at the level that an animal
has yeah that's part of what makes
animals you know this higher form of
existence compared to stones or chalk or
iPhones or cups of coffee how do you
know about this in your senses sets
themselves can you see can you see your
own see here your own here they only
sense what they grasp my dad right does
the intercept actually tell you about
its own organs its own you know go do
this don't do that eat this don't eat
that this is good that's that's bad it
doesn't really tell you about itself but
you need some sort of faculty we call
this reason which can grasp what these
are giving a a splint this is giving but
reason this is very important and this
is again it makes us different reason
also works on itself recent reason can
not only think about the senses or the
inner sense where your body were all
sorts of other things you know you guys
are all prepping for midterm exams right
would be a matter if it's trying to cram
your understanding full of a bunch of
things that you can use later on and if
you actually understand them we'll play
and I'll you connect them together
that's all a matter of reason but reason
can also think about itself have you
every asked yourself is the decision
that I'm making rational have you ever
caught yourself letting your feelings
run away with ya do ya you have used
reason to look at itself in relation to
say your feelings have you ever figured
out that you thought things out wrong
because we've made a decision that's you
reflecting on reason that's not
something that I could do or a kid or
any other animal according to August so
we know these sorts of things by reason
so the reason itself distinguishes
between a servants and what they present
to it and also recognizes what comes
between these in itself and it starts
them to be inserts itself to be their
government reason is supposed to be in
charge and we saw last class right that
sometimes
reason isn't in charged and other things
like what we call the passions desires
you know those can be in charge instead
when people do the wrong thing why is it
because they're they're wrong Longley
directed oriented passion so you know if
I get angry with with the student that I
want to and I shew them how I'm doing
the wrong thing right why did that
happen did it happened because I
reasoned that that wasn't the right
thing to do know when passions drove me
to that and then in certain respect I
was acting in a kind of animalistic way
according to Augustine when were fully
human were being fully rational reason
is completely in charge that's what they
actually makes the will
so let's go on a little bit from from
here he says can we rank these sort of
things is the inner sense better than
the other senses this is yeah what about
reason reason is better than than any of
those why do we think this because it
controls these things each one is sort
of like feeding into the next highest
effect so reason is what judges things
the senses judge sensed you what color
is this okay you just made a judgment
you made another basis of your senses is
it the same color white as this
that's that's judgment too right if your
senses were not that fine
you would actually come to the wrong
judgment and say that's all it's all
just white right but really this is some
sort of more creamy white this is a more
stark white I guess it's saying write
the paper you know which of these is
weird what do you think babe yeah you've
made another judgment you've done that
at the level of the senses does coffee
taste good or bad that's a level of the
face thing should you get coffee right
now do you want coffee how many of you
like pot actually not that many what was
others let's pick something that the
probably everybody likes what's what's
something sweet chocolate anybody
doesn't have to talk about you know like
a chocolate pretended you
you know go be the hot chocolate that's
a judgment being made by the Internet's
somebody puts hot chocolate printing
system there you go you reach your inner
sense is telling you hey that's good
let's have some that does reason makes
to make judges yes now what is reason to
judge it judges everything below it
and it also judges itself and it also
judges in terms of things that are even
tighter than so here's where we're
actually going to get into discussions
about truth and wisdom and Augustine
isn't going to produce an argument for
the existence of God on us so I'm going
to run through this fairly quickly so
that we can we can actually get to all
of us
she says that at a really critical point
if we can find something that you're
certain not only exists but is nobler
that our reason so something higher than
these other degrees of you would you be
willing to call that guy this is worth
thinking about from when we think about
God how do we usually think about I'm
gonna get away from things like you know
old guy with a beard you know can't see
on current is the traditional conception
of God is that God is somehow
transcendent to so what does
transcendent they actually mean means
that got a higher plane of existence
right more than us so can we conceive of
things that are greater those or are we
that you know you guys like this this
this metaphor is a lot of using a page
are we the top of the food chain or the
top of the the ontological benefits
what would be greater than us let's say
we were not worried so much about God we
have some questions like where do we
come from
are there any you know interesting
hypotheses that people bring out of
offices let's say there was an alien
race that produced us right so we're not
yet at God and as a matter of fact let's
say this alien race there's actually
been a whole theory about this stuff
let's say this alien race came to earth
you know every once in a while check up
on us spaceships and you know we thought
these were fiery chariots and that's
where you know chariots fire takes off
from and we sort of data fide that it
made them into God so Zeus was really
some some alien guy who came to check up
on us after you know we've been created
in some sort of you know biologic
laboratory or maybe the evolutionary
process has been guided who knows right
it's all sci-fi so we can make up
anything we like they'd be here that's
right would they be on a higher plane of
existence as they'd be smarter than us
they would it be responsible for our
existence would they really be guys
it depends on your notion gonna miss if
God just means something more powerful
than you that gets the boss you around
and tell you what to do and or
sacrifices you know tell you the little
moral life then maybe that would just be
at this level but if we're really
thinking about something transcendent
with that that sort of alien up well to
transcend just understanding of say in
the moment actions or anything like that
the transcend that would be to know
everything that is to occur and all that
has occurred okay so know that have to
be really really really really smart a
mean beyond that just instead of their
knowledge
it's literally there's no yeah sort of
complete systematics and thank you that
would be something that would be a
higher level
Augustine was going to go a different
way do you think that bring up aliens or
anyone no but you know they've been the
Greeks down sort of weird ideas that
they could have worked with so the
Romans that would have been totally
foreign to them these these ideas that
we haven't speculative fiction as we
call it he focuses on truth
now when we talk about truth we tend to
think about it in terms the truth of
statements or the truth sentences or the
truth of what we're perceiving from the
senses you know if I don't really exist
up here and I'm a hologram I haven't a
certain sense false right or you could
be hallucinating maybe you know some of
you you okay but actually you're
schizophrenic and doctors say there
doesn't exist on the figments of your
diseased imagination where you to some
sort of gruesome genic drug and instead
of having a good trip you're
unfortunately in a philosophy class and
in the morning you know by that spot the
next time around I suppose that's a
sense of truth right we say truth is
when things conform to how we think of
them if I tell you that our midterm is
next week at the very end of class they
hand you a paper and say all right take
the midterm now I lied to you right at
certain point i deceived you
I was untrue with you but there's a
hundred Ruth there's a there's a
conception of truth that obviously has
it's not just individual truths but
truth in general and that's what we use
when we're reasoning as our reference
points for the projection we judge
according to truths and we can talk
about the truth
that we also judged according to truth
with like a capital T and now notice if
we want to say things about these these
eternal truths we have to say that
they're more or less constant right
that's what it means to be eternal or
necessary or things like that like if I
say the whole is greater than any
individual part is that something you
guys recognize is being true that's
always going to be true right if I say
it one plus one equals two
forget about meeting drops one plus one
is going to be equal to two
that's not going to change tomorrow or
depend on your feelings or you know what
works for this this if some culture says
one plus one equals two doesn't work for
us that cats that created slide no ok so
there's some things that reason judges
according to the eternal law that we saw
in the last book but also a lot of other
ideas reason judges according to two
truth and he talks a lot about the truth
of number I'm more interested in some of
these other idea
here we go we ought to live just like is
that true or false it's true is that
gonna change does that depend on how we
feel about it for its truth the better
should be preferred to the worse I mean
if you don't think that you're gonna
have a really hard time if you just like
managing the stuff at this level aren't
you like should be compared with like I
mean when you're making some sort of
judgment that's your decision you should
treat equal cases equally everyone by
them or should we just like leave it you
know whatever you feel like doing
they'll be making yourself your own
standard but notice we judge in terms of
these other standards what we're working
we don't do this all the time do we
leave we make all sorts of exceptions
for ourselves we make bad decisions we
act in ways that are unwise Augustine
would say but when we're actually
functioning on all that cylinders
there's an automobile metaphor
we're actually judging in accordance
with truth now let's think about this
this truth is it higher or lower or on
the same level as could it be lower
it can't be lower why not well because
if it were lower we would be judging
truth it would be something that's up to
us you know it would be something that
we get to decide about here we go it
says if it were lower we would make
judgments about it not in accordance
with so these these basic notions these
basic concepts that you have in order to
make sense out of things you don't get
to pick and choose them to you if you
decide you're going to sort of pick
jiza you're gonna screw up in your
reasoning you have to actually in some
respects aboard get yourself to truth he
says we make judgments about modeling
things because they're lower we often
say that not only is such-and-such true
them but also that it ought to be
similarly not only do we know that our
souls are in a particular state but
often that they ought to be in those
states in making these judgments we
follow the principles of truth within us
which we see income you have the same
plus if you have the same principles of
truth in you yes I do that's what makes
them actually true it better be the same
for you you know one plus one at better
equal to you the same way for you as it
does for me or else we don't have
mathematics right and when it comes to
moral discussion the better is to be
preferred to the worst we'd better all
have some basic understanding of that
that's the same in you as it is me or
else we can't do FX and we can go on and
on and on with him so he says nobody
ever makes these the object of a
judgment so the truth can't be lower
than this
could it be able to same one well let's
think about this he says our our minds
subject to change
yes and in what ways
we talked about changing your minds
right what does that mean yeah so you
form an opinion and then when you
changed it by what happens you replace
it with another opinion that presumable
it's more true thinking right I mean you
could change your mind for the worse as
opposed to well we do this about all
sorts of things you know I used to like
this personally I don't like them
anymore doesn't know who they are you
know I didn't like this person over here
but not like them my mind has changed
but I'm judging in accordance with
certain standards my mind is changing
think about other cases too you know do
we forget things do we make mistakes
when we make mistakes
our mind is either changing for the
worse or or you know we can actually
make a mistake that steers us in the
right direction sometimes all those
happy mistakes but even then he was
still mistaken and wouldn't it be better
to actually know all right so if truth
itself were on the same level of us us
truths would have to change with them
our minds are changeable if it was on
the same level as us then we have to be
malleable like their minds so it has to
be higher than this he says so I had
promised to show you something higher
than our mind and reason so this means
that truth is actually yet higher
in the grand scale of being so he says
this thing itself that this thing is
truth itself embrace it if you can and
enjoy it and he says the supreme good is
known and grasped and the truth in and
since that truth is wisdom let's see in
wisdom the supreme good and grasp and
enjoy
so truth and wisdom are closely
connected with each other where is this
going to exist in the greatest degree
for somebody like Augustine where do you
think it's going to be at the top of
love it's not human beings at the top of
God right God is going to be a truth
incarnate wisdom incarnate truth itself
and in some way every time that we make
the right use of our reason we are
participating in God were connected with
with God in some way
now notice what's going on here he's
provided an argument for the existence
of something that's higher than us do we
want to call that God Augustine says
well you know if you don't want to call
that God then you know you those are
some other places you'd have to figure
out where these truths come from you
know if this is going to be the highest
thing either this is God because that's
what we call the highest thank God or
there's gonna be something higher than
it can you actually think of something
that's that's higher than the truth
itself I mean if your conception of God
is is totally capricious being who makes
the rules then breaks the rules and
stuff
that size of truth but that's not the
traditional Jewish Muslim Christian
conception of God at least as far as so
many like Augustine would go everything
actually are some some some Christian
some juice Muslims who do have a very
capricious conception of God but for
most of the Philosopher's in those
traditions God is going to be this stuff
and we have some of this in us that we
use to sort of guide rules but it's sort
of like you know a little lowercase T
it's a same thing with wisdom Augustine
says we're not actually wise we're
actually quite foolish but we're not so
foolish that we can't recognize that we
need wisdom and then do better when our
reason judges everything else in
accordance with wisdom we become more
wise every time that we do that and
every time that we turn against that we
become more foolish so this is where you
know the things that he's calling the
virtues come in I want to skip ahead now
to talk about the the will itself so
let's let's actually go back over some
of the ideas that we we had talked about
before I remember to turn on the camera
thanks for pointing that out
so other ways would be to go out the
entire class without it why were we
given free love that's what this whole
book was supposed to be about we've gone
through all this stuff about the degrees
being and perception and thinking and
truth and all that sort of stuff
why do I just even go through all of
this stuff in order to come back
eventually to talk
we'll well remember what he said at the
beginning the will was given to us so
that we could use it rightly along with
that was the possibility of musica
wrongly yeah where does will fit in here
so we're around here it's not the
highest thing as a matter of fact it's
what he calls a middle good what does he
mean by by a middle good well the higher
goods are the ones that can't be used
wrongly so what he talks about is the
virtues the virtues are actually over
here connected with truth and wisdom the
virtues would be you know wisdom itself
prudence was business it's the capacity
to make good judgments about what you'll
have do and what not to do justice
justice is the disposition to give
everybody what is their fair their fair
share their due to do the right thing
because you recognize it as the right
thing courage
standing up against adversity for the
things that need to be stood up for you
know defending the weak that's where the
thing is courage temperance keeping the
bodily appetites controlled by reason
not by their own desires or passions or
things like that you can't go wrong if
you really have justice you can't use
justice wrong that's what it means to
have a virtue if you actually have
genuine courage you can't use it wrongly
and if God were to like you know you
know bring you along like scoop up
whatever part of you was was afraid and
cowardly and stick in some other part
that was courageous if you did that sort
of thing you couldn't use it wrongly so
when people pray for courage if they
actually were seeing them they can't go
back Augustine was different
what about your will commando band yeah
man don't we do bad things we do the
willingly
we often say we I didn't choose to do
that that wasn't my intention but if you
started the chain you're you're
responsible
why does the inlet say you'd say we lie
to ourselves a long time when we tell
tell people that other people are
responsible for the way that we are you
know for the choices that we make if
there are choices were responsible so
the will can be used banned the Canton
can other things be used badly to lower
things lower than the low can you use
the census badly sure can you use
technology vample yeah my technology is
very neutral these these people are
always like yeah all our problems are
going to go away but the new iPhone
comes out everything becomes a utopia
they're nuts
because you can you can take anything
you can use this tie you know if you
knew how to do it I don't know did you
could use this tie to kill a person
right this coffee cup could be used for
evil
exactly I can't think of anything not
happen perhaps you could come up with
some scenarios right so penance of
course you know you write terrible
things about people read a nasty note
stick it in somebody's mailbox
that's me right so these things can all
be used for good or they can be used for
bad
the pen is fairly neutral as far as
goods go it's good for a few things your
will though is something so this gets
back to that question
that some of you guys are funny moment
God being a put us to the test or
meaning if there isn't any if there
isn't any free will then it becomes very
difficult to say things like that was a
good action you did the right thing that
was a good choice
and meaning thing like it loses its
significance Augustine says you know the
will itself is is reflexive we can use
the free will itself by means of itself
the will which uses other things in a
certain way uses itself the same way
that the reason reflects on itself the
will chooses its own orientation if
you're on the wrong path you've got the
capacity to say wow I'm screwed up I
need to fix this don't you some of you
have done that already at this point
your life the rest of you probably will
do that that's a point in your way about
something you can all you can also sort
of reaffirm itself you know when you do
the right thing
and you didn't feel like doing the right
thing you can actually sort of reinforce
your will and say I did the right thing
I know this didn't feel good
but I did the right thing I should be
proud of myself now crowd like it moving
over other people are proud of the sense
of taking legitimate joy now in order to
actually have the capacity for doing the
right thing you have to have a free will
and
Augustine ends up saying that it's
better for God to have given us this
will by which we can actually do good
things and sometimes also do bad things
that have not given us this we're going
to talk next time about some of the
intricacies of that what I want to close
with is how these are well good then we
talked about this a little bit last time
he says if we if we look at what makes
the will grid
what is he has to cling he says for turn
itself
remember the will can can move itself
the will has to cling or turn itself to
the unchangeable good to this stuff over
here the will can also go this way
Canton so here's here's a really
concrete scenario somebody says
something very mean to me and they do it
in a mean way
what's my natural response anger breath
we get angry when we feel that somebody
has treated us in a way that we don't we
don't deserve anger itself Augustine
would say is a caption what is anger
it's really a desire to hurt the other
person in response to see them suffer to
punish them in some way this is a common
definition of anger now when I get angry
and there can be some cases where it's
actually legitimate for me to get angry
yeah Augustine thinks that there are
some cases where you want to be angry
you need to be angry nerd so you know
fight off evil to address injustice or
stuff like that
well when I get angry when you get angry
what's our natural tendency is it to
listen to reason to use these sort of
unchangeable rules and we're given you
know how angry want to finally to get at
people do you think
how willing should you be to forgive
people when they screw up and it depends
yeah but you know probably more often
than we do right to most of us err on
the side of getting getting not getting
angry enough or most of us care outside
of gadeuk intuitive what would Augustin
say about that obviously would say
that's actually our choice in this case
the will is deciding should they listen
to reason or should it listen to this
desire that's within us I want to hurt
this person I want to show them I want
other people to see that you can't push
me around like that the little they has
to make a choice which way it's going to
go and if it clings to this it's going
to do right it will be a good will if it
follows the passions it's going to do
the wrong thing and you know each time
that you follow a passion Augustine says
it gets a little bit easier to do it the
next time you know how people get anger
problems
they keep on acting angry right they
keep on doing the wrong thing so he says
when it comes down to it if the will
claims to leave this unchangeable good
it's going to be good if it turns away
from it and decide I want to do
something else instead I want something
for me screw this stuff up here this is
this is too hard to follow I don't want
to hear this right now then the will is
great to make itself back so it's not
God who makes a little bad it's the
person in how they use it the last thing
I'm gonna close with is something I want
to leave you with because there's a
tendency to think that Augustine is
saying well you should always forget
about everything temporal nothing
earthly is good just you know I listen
to God and that's all there is he says
the goods which are sought by sinners
are by no means evil so you know some
people like to drink alcohol bad in
another
no we make the ad use of it sometimes
right
nor does free will you which we have
found must be counted among certain the
middle goods these are not bad things we
misuse them and the misuse of that is
what makes the will ban the misuse never
actually makes the other things banned -
but they're good in themselves
it's our misuse of our wills that are
bad in the process so that's what we
leave